les exercices militaires chinois du mois
dernier ont fait craindre à une invasion
de taïwan
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
taiwan considère qu'il s'agissait d'une
pratique en vue d'isoler lille et
d'imposer un blocus pour forcer la
réunification avec la chine
est
inquiète depuis l'invasion russe en
ukraine la chaîne est plus puissante et
plus influente que la russie croit le
ministre goût plusieurs pays d'asie et
d'amérique latine sont prêts à se
tourner vers le modèle chinois
un appel entendu les politiciens
étrangers se succèdent à taïwan
une délégation canadienne envisage de
s'y rendre le mois prochain le premier
ministre trudeau invite cependant les
élus à considérer les conséquences d'une
telle visite réaction dénoncé par
certains comme une forme de soumission à
la chine mais pas par le gouvernement
taïwanais
mondiale
le ministre espère que les liens
d'affaires avec un canada se
développeront davantage prochainement de
6h à un autre à nadal ce disque racing y
doper ses victoires et j'aurais dit en
juin dernier à tahoua annoncé la
création du comité consultatif et donc
pacifique chargé de formuler des
recommandations au gouvernement
la stratégie canadienne pour contrer
l'influencé de la chine dans la région
risque cependant de ne pas voir le jour
avant l'an prochain il suffit les clubs
la radio canada taipei